okay
welcome welcome everyone this is the
meeting of the executive committee today
the 25th of January everyone's welcome
particularly two members of the public
who I know well so
welcome um I now have to do various
parts of administration around emergency
evacuation
the emergency evacuation announcement
please pay attention thank
you there are no planned fire drills so
if the alarm goes off please leave the
building in an orderly fashion through
the nearest fire exit please use the
fire exit through the main doors of the
hall or the fire exit in the store room
adjacent to the
stage the fire assembly point is the
island in front of the main entrance of
the
building please do not delay your
evacuation evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to the
building until given permission to do so
by Council staff please switch off
mobile phon phones or turn them to
silent please note that the meeting will
be live streamed please ensure that your
microphone members is switched on when
speaking and speak clearly into the
microphone
members of the public are present and I
have to ask you about this members of
the public and press whilst you
are of course entitled to film or take
photographs during this meeting can I
please emphasize to you that this should
be done without disruption to the
meeting and can only be done from a
designated area in the public seating
can I please therefore ask you to raise
your hand clearly in the air if you wish
to take photographs or film this
evening no thank you very
much item one is apologies for absence
we have apologies for absence from
counselor Mrs filmer
Wilson non-members attending there are
none the minutes of the meeting being
held on the 12th of
December
2023 that should
be members I assume you've taken a look
at the
minutes can I sign them as a true and
and appropriate record of the meeting or
are there matters you wish to
raise no no agreed in which case if
agreed then I will sign those at the
appropriate
moment item four to receive Declarations
of
Interest are there any thank you there
are none there are there is one Arthur
thank you chairman Council Williams
thank you chairman um item seven
voluntary sector grants um I have an
interest I'm a trustee or
ravs thank you
thank you very much councilor
Williams councilor
EES as councilor Will Williams has
actually pointed that out I think I
should declare an interest in that my
wife actually receives a grant on behalf
of uh her adoption support group thank
you thank you councilor that will be
these will be noted in the minutes thank
you okay item five questions on notice
from councelors there are
none okay item six
and it's the first with a
report and it's the one team health and
safety
policy uh as councelor Mrs Wilson is is
not here being unwell um I'm going to
ask BB Barnes director of assets and
Investments to introduce the report
thank
you thank you chair um members in front
of you tonight is the one team health
and safety policy this policy has um
been refreshed under the Strategic
partnership across Ward and Brentwood
and applies to our duty as a council to
our staff but also it does note um
duties that are apply to council as well
this policy um then will lead into how
we set out our strategy and our action
plans going forward happy to take any
questions thank
you members are there any
questions councelor Mr new
report thank you chairman um just a
quick question on this I know on the
report that the policies due its next
review April
2024 seems quite a short time period is
that would that be usual or would it
just be an annual review Thanks it would
just be an annual review we started the
work on this um during last summer and
it's just this is the the time it's been
able to come to the executive um but
what we would be doing is we would just
be reviewing it internally as an annual
review and then any material changes we
would bring back for councilors to
endorse
again thank you councilor stany you
indicated you have a
question thank you chairman um I'd like
to know whether it's the council's
responsibility for the Health and
Welfare and safety of it's Partners
that's that's not only the counselors
that that actually are working for the
council but outside contractors thank
you
Fe outside contractors have their own
Duty under their health and safety if
they're a contractor obviously we would
risk assist any um Works being done on
our own Council assets properties and
vice versa on our own premises and in
members of the public but a contractor
would have their own Duty into the
health and safety act as
well are you happy with that I would
just like to know whether we as a
council do inspect
their if you like their health and
safety certification
please so on page
6 22 it does reference to procurement
and
contractors and the partners to the
council so it does make reference that
contractor Partners work on behalf of
council will commit to this policy or
demonstrate an equal grate the
commitment to health and safety and
well-being in their own policies and
arrangements and we would check that and
as part of our risk assessment we would
ask for any documentation that to be
seen before any Works was carried out as
well
Council standing happy with that yes sir
thank
you any further questions
members no none we have I think one
recommendation I'll read it and then
I'll ask for a proposal and second it um
the recommendation noted
R1 it's for members to endorse the draft
one team health and safety and
well-being policy which is attached to
this report at appendix one do we have a
proposer please and second it propose it
proposed by Council Mr Newport seconded
by councelor
Stanley uh can I take a show of hands
please for those in favor of the
recommendation okay is that unanimous
yeah it is thank
you thank you very
much now move to item seven which is the
voluntary sector grants allocation
decision for
2425 uh councilor Julie Gooding is here
um we have um Kim
Anderson uh on behalf of
communities um if I
may councelor Gooding I'll ask kenison
to speak first and ask you if there's
anything you wish to add thank you Kim
thank you chair um so the report before
members is to agree the 225,000
allocation out of the 2425 budget which
supports the CVS and voluntary sector
organizations in the district and
specifically to continue to run the
£10,000 grants process for local
organizations and projects so the
agreement by the executive will allow
the grants process to be released and
the council would look to run this um
for four weeks during the month of
February um the process also allows the
council to top slize £15,000 which
supports
ravs um and the idea is with the lead
member to establish a cross party um
panel that will actually score the
applications that are submitted as part
of this process um and these
organizations should be demonstrate how
they support the rord district council
business plan and also the health and
wellbeing strategy
priorities um decision paper will then
come back to the executive group I think
in the report it says April but because
of pre-election considerations it will
probably be June I think um that will
include the results of the grants
process for
2425 and the funding allocation to those
organizations it will also provide an
update on the new S6 voluntary sector
infrastructure model SO waiting for the
outcome of that and also I believe that
it provides an annual update from rabs
on the work that they've done in the
previous year I'm happy to take any
questions
thank thank you Kim um before I ask the
questions councilor Gooding do you wish
to um draw attention do anything from
members
make thank
you thank you chair yes um I would like
to say that the voluntary sector Grant
gives invaluable support and without
this we would lose a lot of Goodwill in
the community uh many groups rely on the
grants and donations in the district um
I've contacted some of the recipients
and from the previous allocation to gain
their feedback on the voluntary sector
funding what difference it's made to
them um am I able to just give you a
quick flavor of
that of course yeah okay so thank so bar
on bus they they're a local um youth
group they provide provided um
volunteers with training for the year so
instead of working ad hoc they've
actually got a planned program for for
young for you youth work to be uh put
into the community by volunteers which
is uh that they're a great
organization and send the right message
is for a disabled community and and they
are financially struggling um people in
the community have struggled with the
cost of living they've given out fuel
vouchers winter coat vouchers and
shopping support um and east6 hack space
is um a 3D printer that they got with
their funding and this is multimaterial
printer which enables medical grade
materials for use in Prosthetics and
they've been able to print uh pill
bottle openers for people with arthritis
they work very closely with remap which
is a charitable organization for people
with disabilities that they wouldn't get
these this equipment on the NHS so it is
bespoke items um you know I I could go
on and on because trust links also um
they've got a smart board on order that
they are working with people with
disabilities as well um I won't take up
any more of your time but only to say
that the work that they do is is
fantastic we just a small small amount
of money so I would recommend certainly
um recommendation one to get this grant
out and uh to to ensure that we can do
that in the four weeks in
February thank
you thank you Council good thank you so
much for um the
uh the small picture of how things have
been going well um for the organizations
we've supported and um obviously we look
forward to a more formal present a of
that in June but nevertheless thank you
so
much members uh I'm going to ask you at
this point to indicate whether you want
to ask any
questions I have councelor EES right in
front of me can you put your hands a
little bit higher please thank that's
good because otherwise I'm not sure
whether you're trying to play Pake with
me or we're indicating so councelor e
thank you thank you chair um in regards
to recommendation two how much risk is
there around that because obviously
there's we're looking to okay uh the the
grant allocation tonight um but there is
a good deal of uncertainty as to how
this is actually going to go ahead um it
does seem as though ess6 might be uh
giving us a little bit of a headache
here I can respond to that we're at the
moment with ESS County Council and their
infrastructure I think the first 12
months is going to be business as usual
while they do a transition into whatever
that new structure looks like I think
when you're looking at local
organizations such as ravs I think
there's still a place for them it's just
how money are allocated out so whether
ess6 just want one contract with an
organization and then that's
subcontracted out to the various CVS's
that sit across Essex we don't know that
yet so again there is an element of risk
but we are waiting on ess6 and what we
want to do from a local Authority
perspective to minimize that risk to our
local organizations that support our
[Music]
residents could could I just um
interject there and say obviously you're
in very close touch with what's going on
at Essex and uh if there is any
increased or perceived risk then will
you please um let me know and let Julie
Gooding know in particular so that we
can arrange for an an intervention thank
you councilor Stanley thank you chairman
um just two questions really one is is
there a top limit that the grant is
accessible to those that are asking for
the grant and two is does there does it
make any difference to that Grant if
they are within their getting grants
from other directions thank
you I will double check the grant
process here because it's probably
slightly different from what I'm used to
in brenwood I think the the the majority
applications are usually for up to
,000 um and again you may they may ask
for ,000 but they may only be awarded
£500 so I think there's probably a
question back to those organizations say
with 500 pound say are you still able to
deliver some of the the what you want
out of that Grant application so I think
we'd always have that discussion with
those organizations to make sure that
they are able to deliver that or if they
say no we can't then that goes back into
the pot to be
reallocated Council Gooding yeah just to
add to um what uh Kim has has already
alluded to when we as a cross panel
party of of members are making the
decision for how much it they do need to
meet the criteria of the health and
well-being board and so if they haven't
demonstrated enough um within their
application then we as a cross party
member May reduce that amount if we
don't feel they've met the criteria
which ultimately then stretches it out
to some extra people so through their
own fault for not explaining it very uh
well maybe not meeting the criteria um
we end up getting more people covered
with the 500 as opposed to the thousand
thank you councilor
nle thank you chairman um I just wanted
to come back to um recommendation to um
if I make Kim where you said that we
might not be able to meet that April
2024 date and it might need to be pushed
back
further I think that's just purely
because of pre-election consideration so
and and that's absolutely fine but I
sorry I
and I just wanted to ask Emily on that
on whether we should make an amendment
to that recommendation because we're
moving to a committee system and whether
that should then be pushed into a
committee because obviously we won't
have an executive post May elections or
whether or not we should be taking this
decision before the
elections and is that feasible that we
could do it at the ne
during that period um or is that sorry
is that clear yeah thank you it's it's
clear enough to me I understand what
you're saying I'm sure Emily you all
knows equally Emily
please thank you chair um so there are
two parts to that question the first
part is around the ability to take a
decision during the pre-election
moratorium on the award of the voluntary
sector grants um and actually that could
continue to go ahead
During the pre-election period the issue
is that the council can't then do any
publicity around it so the pre-election
period doesn't stop you from taking
decisions it just stops you from talking
about them um the second part is is
absolutely right so um from uh May 2024
from the annual council meeting the
executive will no longer uh be a part of
the council's governance structure so um
if the decision is put back into the new
Municipal year it will need to go to the
committee yes
Council thank thank you Emily for that
um my view would be personally to keep
to that April deadline if we can um
regardless of publicity these grants are
obviously important and we don't really
want to stall the process at all I think
so that would be my view thank
you ch
Mr Newport are you proposing an
amendment to R2 no no okay
okay standy you
indicated yes thank you chairman my
second question was on the grant
situation would that have any bearing as
to other grants that that that company
or those people that are asking for the
grants would that have any bearing on
there our grant to them
I think what we would do within the
application process is to ask them what
other grants they've received um and
again the timelines on that so have they
have those grants been approved or are
they just um in the process of getting
those agreed or not I think that's all
we can do as part of the application
process okay um sorry I looked should
have looked up a little quicker looking
down councilor
Hoy thank you chairman I just would like
a bit of clarification after what's been
spoken about to my
mind we either vote for R1 or for R2 R1
begins to continue to run the 10K Grant
process R2 starts to change the current
process so I'd like clarification
if we are voting for one or two or they
can actually both exist together because
the way they're written in my head don't
exist
together I think that's probably a
slight error in the report what I would
say is R1 is for to continue that Grant
process that's not changed I think there
was a delay last year and it didn't go
out till later so I think the idea is
that it comes back and we get those
Grants awarded as quickly as possible so
sorry for the confusion in the report so
so sorry chairman I just say for clarity
that means our R1 then runs into R2
effectively is that
correct yeah so so R1 and R2 exist
together I'm going to take um Mr Summers
to speak um sorry Julie I'm gonna thank
you chair because he'd like
to sorry yeah thank you chair so I think
the the wording is the the current
process in our to do is that they would
have come back later in the year
possibly June or July for the for the
actual results of the crosswork party so
what we're suggesting is that that comes
actually comes back a lot earlier than
it would have done previously and that's
that's the change of the
process Council gning so do we need to
change this recommendation to because at
the moment it doesn't read that at
all um I'm with you um please if if
there's an amendment that needs to be
put forward will someone please make
it
Council so in in light of that I think
R2 just needs to be amended to to
continue the current process I think
that would resolve that issue just
changing that word would that be accept
[Music]
and if that's an amendment it needs a
second councilor
Gooding in which case as there's an
amendment before we take
R1 R2 and
R3 um I will be asking you
to um we've got a proposal in
seconder and now we'll put that
Amendment to the vote so those of you
you in favor of the change from to
change to to continue the current
process etc etc um will you please
indicate now in
favor that's taken thank
you any any further questions
members if there are none I will ask ask
you whether you're happy to take R1 R2
R3 um to together or would you like to
vote on them
separately together together
okay then I will read them out I will
need um proposer and seconder for the
three recommendations
please I've got councelor
Gooding and councelor Williams
sorry oh you didn't want to Second it
okay well just hold on um councelor
Stanley is seconding right you you've
got a question that's fine thank you
Council thank you as a trustee of R
should I vote on this or shall I
obstain my choice I
presume okay thank you chair I'm I'm
happy to um answer that in a very vague
way I'm afraid counselor um it is your
personal choice to determine whether or
not you have an interest that Pro
prohibits you from voting but I would
always say if in doubt it's best to not
vote thank
you okay thank you very much Emily right
I'm going to read the recommendations at
this point before we take a vote on all
three at the same time okay or
concurrently R1 to continue to run the
10K grants process for local owners
organizations and projects agreement of
this by the executive would allow the
grants process to be released and run
for four weeks during February a
cross-party members panel to be formed
for March by the lead member and the
panel dates set with the Salient
information from the applications to
score against the RDC business plan and
the hwb strategy
priorities to continue the current
process and allow for a decision paper
to come back to the executive group in
April
224 to include the results of the grants
process for
2425 provide an update on the new Essex
model agree RDC approach and funding
allocation and also provide full results
and outcomes from the voluntary sector
grants given out in
2324 including a full year report of
activity from ravs to support rav's
resilience in the interim with a
transition payment of
10K
10,000 which has been identified within
the business case for the Ukraine Grant
monies that's R1 R2 R3 I'll take votes
in favor of the set of 123 please okay I
have we have
okay okay thank you how many is that
eight eight in
favor um I now have to ask anybody
against any extensions Council Williams
have that um those three recommendations
are carried thank
you
I should I should do that more
often sounded like karate didn't
it okay um item eight asset decisions
you have a
report um from councilor Mrs Wilson who
we know is absent due to illness but we
have um BB Barns here the director of
assets and Investments
um who has agreed to lead on the
presentation of the report thank you
thank
you if I may upon reflection I I I think
I to declare an interest in the um AR
Lane element of this report having
camped many times on the site with the
scouts being involved with the scouts
still to some extent being DBS checked
by the scouts Etc and available to Camp
there and and
I think I not vote on that basis I think
it's wise thank you councilor H that
will be managed accordingly and the fact
that you've decided not to vote on that
particular
item thank you chair um members in front
of you this evening is
um six recommendations just to note
recommendations six is incorrect and it
should read um to Delegate for it to
director asset investments in
consultation with Lee member of assets
and Open Spaces to fin the terms
proposed in R1 through to R5 at the
moment it says R for um apologies I
missed that
um hold on a TI um I when we get to that
recommendation I'll have to ask for an
amendment from
Members no it can just be proposed as
amended okay so can you make it clear to
me so in um R6 um the R4 needs to be
replaced with R5 thank you thank you
simple eror yeah just yeah apologies for
that thank you um there are five leases
or licenses in front of you um to be
approved tonight um as highlighted in
the report the team have been working
through some leases and Licensing that
have
been um overhanging and we have just
been aligning and kind of getting our
house in order this wouldn't usually
come at allog together at this point in
time but this is the time I've been able
to bring this report forward working
with the lead member so um we have a
lease of lands to the sou South AR Lane
to the Scout Association for a period of
28 years lease of land and Hut at conal
Road in R to the reserve forces and
condex Association for a period of 25
years license of Office Space um and the
meeting room at M Hall arts and events
center to the citizens of ice Bureau for
a period of two years a license at the
day Center at backlane
Rochford to the citizen viice Bureau for
a period of two years and a lease of the
day Center at backlane to the trustees
of old people's welfare Community for a
period of seven years the report
highlights what the rentals are some are
peorn some are in are in 800 ping and
some are higher and obviously
collectively over the years one will um
where is it
sorry the Air Cadet one will be over
50,000 um all the leases are would say
um and Licensing they have brake Clauses
in them they have in the leases there's
opportunity to reflect on the the rental
as well um happy to take any questions
on any specific one
thank you Phoebe um members questions oh
there's one next to me
councelor Newport councelor yes Mr
Newport sorry chairman did you mind if I
glass water not all definitely
[Music]
not we going to wait for M to come back
yes we're going to wait till the member
returns to his seat thank you I think he
should
run we're still in session councelor
Stanley thank
you coun
Lis
sorry can you Emily's want the heating
off want the heating off oh excellent
yes what a good idea thank you
okay again we'll wait until
um the administration's
done
thank you
Emily um to
resume councelor Mr nle thank you
chairman
um Phoebe can you um explain just in
layman's terms the difference between a
lease and a license and one of the ite
um recommendations
R2 no um sorry not R2 R3 about the M
Hall um that
license is that can that license be
changed if um uh operator came forward
that needed that space as part of their
operating model
thanks thank you so a license
um is to used to kind of um spec specify
a specific area so and he usually for a
short duration uh lease is for fixed
longer periods and is of exclusive
occupation so the question you ' got
regarding R2 is the
R3 R3 um is that the licence is for the
cab to have use of the off of a specific
office space and the the meeting room
they do not have exclusive rights to the
m hwart Event Center regarding your
point around if an operator was to come
forward we there is a a break clause in
there of six months which would allow us
the time to find them alternative
accommodation um which is an reasonable
amount of time for them to us find
support them in find alternative
commentation move them out in to operat
to come
in thank
you any other questions members Chris
councilor
standing thank you chairman
um having read through some of well
having read through best part of our
assets I just would like to ask the
question of do we know that the
lease value that we've put on these
assets do we know that
the renter will be able to afford the
rents or the lease that we've got on
there and I'm considerably worried that
we've got such a long term on two of
them of 28 and 25 years
um I'm I'm particularly concerned with
that because you're you're looking too
into the future to to understand what is
going to go on with those groups
um that's that's my concerns thank you
thank you phbe if you could deal with
that thank you um so obviously we are to
the proposals we have put forward have
been agreed with who we have been
negotiating the leases and licenses with
and we are comfortable that them
organizations can pay the the current
proposals in the report regarding the
long lease terms um with um
organizations like Scout groups and that
we give them long lease terms because it
enables them to be able to apply for for
funding um for the Air Cadet one they
want to put considerable amount of um
enhancements into the facility that's
why they've been gr a leas so they have
exclusive occupation um in some
circumstances um Grant applications
won't award any grants if the lease is
less than 25 years so sometime so
organizations come forward so they can
get their lease extended so that they
can apply and get grant
funding do you want to come
back yes please chairman um with that in
mind then um obviously in 20 28 years
from now we don't know what our costs
would be or what the cost would be would
they be able to meet those do is that is
that the enlightened view or of of the
life
see yep so within the leases there is
break Clauses there are rent reviews and
the reviews allow us to have them
conversations I um once at seven years
so to say to to look at the market rent
again look at the rental value and then
also look at kind of the backdrop of the
organizations of if they can afford a
rent increase at that time or not if
they can't then no rent increases
proposed or uh a negotiated rent
increase is proposed but the the the
leases are um written so that we can
have they can serve noce we can serve
break cles but also rent reviews are
periodical we carry them out and um so
we're not yeah we're not stuck in a
lease for a long term that someone can't
afford there's
opportunities okay thank you uh Council
Williams your
next ad thank you chairman um I'm a
little concerned about the percentage
increase in in the rents it does it will
sound to other people the same our Red's
gone up by 17 times that sounds awful
although we know it's not why does the
day Center not pay very much at all and
also cab they don't pay much at all
they're quite a a reasonably Rich
organization and I understand that we're
also responsible for the upkeep of those
buildings yeah so my understanding with
the c is we do have a partnership
agreement with them and it's most likely
in the partnership agreement I'd have to
go away and check
that we provide a facility for them to
operate um when we award peorn went it
we allward looking at the social value
so without them Services what they
deliver to organization the council
would potentially having to deliver them
services so by awarding a pepper corn
rent then the reach of the social value
which is quable we don't have that at
that point in time is greater than what
the market rent is at that point what we
can get for the the side
yeah thank you Phoebe can you um examine
that question and circulate members with
the uh position um is is it um enshrined
in a an agreement particularly with um
with r was it the C yeah the cab and
also with the day Center if you wouldn't
thank
you councilor Rees councel William
question thank
you councelor Mr newort thank you
chairman um so I'll just touching back
on what councelor Williams said about
the 17 times increment is this
because those um those leases haven't
been reviewed over that period and going
into the future um coming back to what
council stany said about the length of
those leases are these rents linked to
any indexation
CPI anything so we don't get into that
position again where we see a large jump
in um rents thanks yeah you are correct
some of the increases is due to the
rents being have been held over and
we've not reviewed them and
therefore for for for an amount of time
and therefore the rents have increased
after reviewing so yes getting our house
in order now means that we're in a
position where we can regular review
them and they will be linked to
um or to a r revaluation where we would
get an independent evaluation done on
them at that time which takes into
consideration or inflation and that but
that will be as part of the rent reviews
I stated out in the
leases councelor Stanley I've got you
just just one just one other question
which uh hasn't been put down on any
other prices and that is do we I I don't
know so this is the question do we
charge VAT on
those
leases no we'd only charge VAT on the
acis if the buildings were opted to were
had been opted to tax for vat and from
my recation none of the buildings are
opted to tax at the
moment councilor H uh thank you chairman
um just very quickly then on social
value which was mentioned it is possible
to give values for social value I'm not
saying do it this for now but future
could we put the social value down then
to to show that the social value is is
what we think it is thank
you thank you councilor Hy any further
questions
members right there aren't any um I'm
going to handle this slightly
differently because of um the
Declaration of Interest I'll take R1
first and then I'll ask you whether
you're prepared to take R2 to uh R six
together are you agreeable with that
approach okay that case I'll take uh R1
with a proposer and seconder
please propos Council Newport councilor
Rees um I shall make sure I read these
out because that's the right and proper
way
R1 to lease the council owned asset
known as land to the south of Ark Lane
Hall Road Rochford to the Scout
Association trust
Corporation for use as a scout unit and
purposes ancillary there too and for the
activities
undertaken by the voluntary youth
organizations for a period of 28 years
those in favor
please right that's uh eight all
right um
anybody against any vote
against any
[Music]
exstension sorry could I just ask advice
is it best I don't vote or
abstain it essentially um is the same
conclusion so it's fine for you to
abstain one abstention thank you that um
R1 is
carried as it your wish to take R2 to R
six um I thought one of them was being
removed
no
sorry right I'm putting R2 to R six
forward sorry can I just interrup do we
have to actually uh note there that R
six has been changed
no I will read out the amended as
proposed by uh Phoebe Barnes okay thank
you I check that before we commenced our
questions and debate thank you right I
do have to read this out I apologize for
the sound of my own voice for a few
minutes but
nevertheless if it sends you to sleep I
shall wake you up for the next item
thank you okay R2 to leas the council
owned asset known as part of land and
Hut at Conor Road ra with around
.47 Acres aged red on the map annexed
here too to appendix as appendix to to
the reserve forces and Cadets
Association for East Anglia the tenant
for use as a training center for air
training core for a period of 25 years
are three to license the council owned
asset known
as part of part of office space and
meeting room at the mil hearts and M
arts and events center ra colored red on
the floor plan Ann next here to as
appendix 3 to Rochford and Ry citizens
advice Bureau the l e for use as a
counseling and advice Center for a
period of two years are four to license
the council owned asset known as part of
day Center at Back Lane Rochford colored
blue on the map annexed here to as
appendix 4 to Rochford and Ry citizens
advice Bureau limited the licen E for
use as a counseling and advice Center
for a period of two
years r five to lease the council owned
asset known as as part of day Center at
Back Lane rodford edged red on the map
Annex here to is appendix 5 to Trustees
of old people's welfare committee for
Rochford and District the tenant for use
as a day center for the elderly for a
period of seven years R six to delegate
authority to the director of assets
investments in consultation with the
lead member of assets and Open Spaces to
finalize the
terms proposed in R1 through to R5 as
outlined in this report do I have a
proposer and seconder for each of those
items we've got councilor Mr Newport
Council Miss Newport that makes it a
family affair so thank you um members
I'll take votes in favor of the items R2
to R six
please
yeah that's that's unanimous thank
you no votes against so I'll take it as
no further voting is
required thank you
members we now move to item
nine which uh is the
22425 budget and 2429
medium-term Financial strategy
report um I understand councilor Hoy
you're going to present to this uh this
item and that there was circulated
yesterday a um lead members
recommendation thank you yes
um this is the um proposed budget draft
budget for um
425 the um headline proposals are a
council tax increase of
2.99% which equates to an increase of 15
P per week on bandid
property no Custer Services no borrowing
over the medium-term financial
strategy fees and charges generally
Rising with
inflation investment in the relocation
of our offices and in
mhall we can present a balanced budget
for next year as well as a balanced
budget for
2025 26 and 20 26 27 with no use of
reserves to support those
budgets this demonstrates a sound
responsible approach to managing the
council's finances despite severe
pressure on budgets as a result of
inflation um as an
overview there is a great deal of
uncertainty regarding the economic
backdrop and government funding for the
budget and
mtfs the mtfs continues the council
policy of not
borrowing that does not mean that future
borrowing is out of the question for the
right projects but not for this
report we can maintain our minimum level
of working balances of 10% of net
revenue expenditure as per Council
policy and acceptable to the section1
officer over the next three
years the labing paragraph 7.2
summarizes budgets for 5 years these
there are projected shortfalls in years
four and five whilst these shortfalls
are of some concern they are only
predictions and in the context of
substantial uncertainty that's how they
should be
treated despite this uncertainty we
nonetheless wish to highlight some
actions planned over the medium-term
designed to generate income and reduce
costs these are set out in paragraph
6.5
the capital
program we are presenting a five-year
program that invests in the district and
the services of the count that the
council provides but to avoid borrowing
we are using receipts from asset sales
and earmarked
reserves again I would like to emphasize
this does not preclude borrowing in
future years this is the budget as we
see it today the e mar reserves that we
use to fund the capital program come
from the revenue budget sometimes
building them up when we can to spend on
investment the amount of reserves
available to fund the capital program
will become
exhausted obviously this has been
recognized by limiting the program over
the 5 years whilst we have identified
some specific schemes a number of others
will be subject to a value for money
assessment starting in
2425 to decide which should be
prioritized this is explained in
paragraph
13.4 so as we've I've explained there's
very little room for maneuver we
continue to be as efficient as possible
but there are ongoing cost increases and
pressure on income any spare funding
will be used to support investment in
assets and services the over the overall
position is delicate any significant
unfunded cost could promote or prompt
the need to reduce services or to borrow
if the counseling tax increase was
reduced by 1% It was cost £450,000
over the mtfs period and 90,000 every
year thereafter our Mar reserves are set
out in paragraph 15.9 they demonstrate
how reserves are used to fund the
capital program at the start of this
year they still at 13.3 million but are
projected to fall to just below5 million
at the end of next
year the use of these reserves is
planned and they are not being used to
fund ongoing expenditure only one of
costs but their projected reduction does
highlight how this Council along with
most other councils across the country
is having to utilize reserves to to
sustain
Services I just like to point out the
report does refer to funding from the UK
SPF
fund this I'd just like to say this the
report on the UK SPF fund is going to
the executive on the 8th of February so
we are assuming there's assumptions made
that that would be approved in this
report um on the 8th of February I'm
expecting that to be approved hopefully
so I'll just like to say that the
process from this point is as follows
this executive meeting will discuss and
approve its budget and MTF mtfs
proposals for full Council on the 20th
of February the overview and scrutiny
committee will scrutinize these
proposals on the 1st of February making
any recommendations to the
executive the executive will meet again
on the 8th of February to consider these
recommendations and finalize its
proposed budget mtfs to the council for
tonight I propose that the five
recommendations related to the budget
mtfs be put to for Council on the 20th
of February for those I think OB here
was a bit of juggling there but for
those who don't know mtfs stands for a
medium-term financial strategy thank
you thank you councilor Hoy I would just
like yeah I'd just like to point out
that the only recommendation in front of
us this evening is R1 which is on the
supplemental sheet and just to focus
your minds um I'm not asking it to be
voted upon uh the recommendation is that
the draft budget report be submitted to
the overview and scrutiny committee for
review it does not include any of R1 to
R5 included in the draft report thank
you Mr
Willis thank you thank you chair you
made the point that I was about to to
make to supplement what council Hoy said
in that case my training is complete
thank
you members um you're welcome to ask
questions of councilor Hoy and Mr
Willis councilor Gooding councelor Crips
counc St yeah okay let's
go thank you um for the report that
you've you've explained so far can I
just ask for some clarification on
13.5 uh page
9.12 uh the program includes the 1.4
million allocation for Rochford District
Council Office
relocation I just want clarification
it's is that just a straight relocation
from South Street to the Civic Suite
because it doesn't include any temporary
accomodation councel Gooding can I
remind you that matters you're referring
to matters that are in exempt okay you
cannot continue to speak of those in
Open Session thank you very much would
you like to re reconsider your question
please how can I reward
it can can I ask
for I just need a breakdown of what the
1.4 million allocation is
fall is that
possible M Willis can you
help I hope so chair um thank you
Council good um all I can say at the
moment is it's an allocation which is
true of a number of items within the
capital program um we need to um make
our best estimates of various investment
items within the capital program over
five years um and sometimes we have very
little detail to go on and sometimes
there are business cases required in
order to decide even if certain things
go ahead certainly in what form they go
ahead um when there is so much
uncertainty and that is true of the 1.4
million that's in the program So my
answer is no there is no breakdown
because we haven't worked that out yet
what the 1.4 million represents is the
value of capital receipts that will be
generated which is shown in the appendix
thank
you councilor Crips thank you
um I'll just say before um we do
continue will members make take
particular care over not referring to
matters in exempt if you do so I'm
afraid after this warning there there
may be difficulties so thank
you uh my point is for Tim it's quite a
broad Point as opposed to specifics your
report quite rightly regularly through
it issues warnings and cautions about
the um fragility of the estimate
government indecision inflation etc etc
etc and then at the end towards the back
end section 17
conclusions um you explain some of the
measures we're taking to cope with it
and so on um and
17.1 uh paragraph
17.1 the last sentence end with these
factors could jeopardize the council's
sustainable financial position without
continued budgetary vigilance alongside
the delivery of the council's priorities
so my question to you Tim is would you
recommend given the fragility of the
situation that we introduce perhaps a
quarterly health check on
the Essential Elements of the the
document um that being Revenue capital
and reserves so that we are
actually monitoring it enough to be
aware of any going wrong of course
because of these pressures that you
identified so it's a question you know
is it time that we should start to
monitor this more clearly to control it
thank
you Mr Willis I think I know what you're
going to
say thank you chair um first of all i'
I'd point out to to councilors that
there's a section 14 in this this report
which is in any budget report um for any
local Authority the section 25 statement
which is the Assurance statement by the
statutary finance officer which provides
the assurance that that the the um the
estimates that Council are that have in
front of them are robust and that
reserves are adequate for determining
the level of the budget for next year
and C tax which offers some of that
Assurance I think um that you're that
you're seeking um the other thing I
would say is um there are certain
statutary officers that have a statutary
obligation to the law to protect certain
things for every Council and as as you
know one of those is the section1
officer the post that I'm covering for
at the moment and it's essential that
the person in that post lives and
breathes exactly those concerns that you
raise on a daily basis never mind
quarterly um so it's if there was any
question that that it was likely that
the section that you referred to in the
in the conclusion that there was
potential for any accounts to be
jeopardized and the the financial
sustainability of the council were to be
undermined then that would be a matter
that I bring before certainly first of
all the other statutary officers and
then this executive and the four Council
um to warn of that very fact and I'm
obligated statutorily to do so um so
that would be the the the protection
that I would suggest that that you have
against those sorts of sorts of
scenarios ultimately of course it's a
section 114 but that would be a last
result and we're certainly a long way we
nowhere near that right now thank
you thank you Mr Willis councelor Crips
you have a return yes please Tim in no
way was I insinuating that uh you're not
doing the officers Duty it's just that
there seem to be so many risks which are
not within our control that this feels
like it's more likely to be a problem
given the state of the budget situation
so um I'm encouraged that you monitor it
daily and are obliged to bring it to our
notice should it go anywhere near being
a so thank you for
that thank you councelor Crips was it um
who was
next Chris Council
Stanley thank you chairman um taking it
a little bit further on from councilor
cribs uh who who's put it quite
eloquently um on
9.13
um where it is noted that we are facing
challenging
times um
and pressures and increased demand in
the future I just and this is really the
mtfs which is the medium term in five
years from now can he can he say and
which he has done here is saying I am
satisfied that the council has
sufficient reserves and balances to
operate over this medium term
um have we got exactly that in say in
five years time would we have the
Reserves for uh
emergencies of flooding and with climate
change and and what what we have to to
to deal with as a council would we have
those reserves there for not only of
what we're dealing with at this present
time but
for climate change in in the future
um we we all know that rainy is a is a
really a bowl for water and and the way
it transfers down from the town center
and I just wonder if we have got those
reserves in place for that sort
of
eventuality in the first
case Council stonia must um remind you
that um rter District Council is not the
flood Authority so you're referring to
floods in particular so I need to to
mention that to you as I think you know
but um Mr Willis if you could um address
the general um approach to that
question thank you chair thank you
councelor Stanley D um I I'll answer
this in quite a narrow Financial way the
the table um on it's page 9.8 uh
paragraph 7.2 um sets out the fiveyear
position of reserves and the it's all a
bit small I'm afraid but the there's a
there's a row there just below the
second green bar which is general fund
contribution or
withdrawal um and it's 00 and then it's
04 so £4,000 for the next three years
that shows that we've got a balanced
budget for the next three years is our
projected expenditure equals our
projected income um but then there's
880,000 and then 1.2 million 1.2 78
million in the following two years which
is a short fall it's a budget Gap a
deficit what you going to call it so um
as was mentioned by Council Hy's
introduction we we know a little about
2425 next financial year we know very
little beyond that so these are
projections into the relative L longterm
five years which is a longer term
medium-term Financial strategy that this
Council has traditionally considered
it's been three or four years five years
exceptionally long um so the amount of
uncertainty there is
substantial um underlying your your
question I think is if we've got
projections that are deficits are we
doing something about it to avoid it and
the answer to that is first of all the
amount of uncertainty means that it
would it would be a bit premature do
something about it now that's something
that might happen in or might not in 5
years time but more seriously it's the
if we were to take action now to address
something that may or may not happen in
five years you could end
up stopping Services making
redundancies um
taking action to withdraw investment
when you didn't need to as the years
passed you would realize that you didn't
need to because we we got the
predictions wrong so it's a balance to
be struck between knowing whether or not
in this in this scenario which
is which over the next five years we do
have deficits in years four and five
knowing that should we take action now
or not and my response to to that is we
needn't take action now having three
years worth of a balanced budget is very
good actually in in the current
environment Financial environment um but
we do suggest that you have you commit
to various action planned action over
the medium term to start considering
ways in which you will address those
things and some of those are set out in
the report but in a very narrow
Financial sense if we've got 880,000
that we need to fund in in year four and
of the fiveyear mtfs and another 1.27
eight million in year five um you will
see that the uh the bottom the row below
that is the general fund balance that's
how sort of the the the that we try and
maintain at 10% of net revenue
expenditure so that's the cash the sort
of the last result cash that we draw
upon well that goes negative at the end
of five years it means we're we've got
800,000 less than we've got in it so
that can't be the case however um in
that worst case scenario if we took no
action to address those deficits as they
approached over the years and that
actually happened we still have
earmarked reserves now some of those ear
marked reserves are what they say
they're IR marked for something specific
and we might need them for those
specific things but some of them are
Provisions for certain circumstances and
those ones could be called upon in fact
would be called upon to help bridge that
Gap in that scenario we would still have
sufficient reserves over the five years
even if those deficits happened in years
four and five so that ultimately gives
you the protection that we're not going
to run out of reserves based on these
projections thank you Mr
any further questions members he looks
around no in which case um I'm going to
on your behalf and on behalf of the
committee um R1 the recommendation is
that the draft budget report chairman
wouldn't it be more appropriate as it's
my report for me to propose no I'll make
it from the chair and you and I will ask
propos and seconder I wish to make
absolutely clear what we're actually
putting forward
uh R1 that the draft budget report be
submitted to the overview and scrutiny
committee for review have we got a
proposal and seconder
please I misunderstood you chairman I
will propose it proposed by councilor
Hoy seconded by Council e thank you I'll
now take votes in favor of the
recommendation
please can you show a hand nice and high
so I can see it we can all see it yes
that is unanimous so thank you very much
I believe we've now reached the end of
the uh agenda meeting so I will thank
you very much for uh attending I would
also like to thank all the officers who
have come this evening um to assess the
committee in making the decisions that
have been put forward in the
recommendations thank you very much
indeed I close the meeting at
8:39 something like
that you're always my
arbiter